heavy fighting continues in eastern
Ukraine withdrawn and missile attacks on
major cities and infrastructure Russia's
President Putin is leading his war of
aggression no matter the cost
the war is bringing death and
destruction to Ukraine but it is also
changing power structures in Europe
Poland and the Baltic states are gaining
Traction in the EU and NATO many Eastern
Europeans are taking responsibility and
display leadership while Western Europe
appears to dither we ask the war in
Ukraine is Eastern Europe leading the
continent's response
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point let me
introduce today's panel that's Frank
Hoffman Eastern Europe correspondent at
DW
and there's a vendelina Von brero Berlin
correspondent and birchy for The
Economist magazine and joining us from
Bonn another DW colleague Roman
goncharenko from our Russia desk
and I'd like to start with you uh Roman
looking at the front lines right now
what kind of help does you cry Ukraine
need right now
well it hasn't changed Ukraine still
needs um ammunition it needs more
weapons heavy weapons like tanks like
long-range missiles because we are now
dealing with a de facto
um stalemate Russia is trying to um to
achieve some some uh try and training
offensive in the eastern Ukraine by the
city of bakmut in the region of Donetsk
because Russia is trying to compensate
for the
um defeated head just a few months ago
in eastern Ukraine and in southern
Ukraine uh in regions like kharkif and
her song So Russia is just trying to
copy its success as of June where he
could
um just
successfully attack and occupy several
Ukrainian towns there and um as the
winter is coming it's very cold and the
ammunition is being used very very fast
Ukraine needs more ammunition and more
heavy weapons Roman as you just said
winter is approaching it's clear that
Ukraine of course needs further help the
USA aside one could see that Eastern
European nations are the most important
supporters right now is their view on
this wall the view from the East
further east is it more accurate than
the Western View well it's proven to be
more accurate certainly in terms of you
know they them in particular Poland but
other countries too warning about
Russian Russia about the danger posed by
Russia and US sort of until recently
dismissing it a little bit as you know
panic and and and the polls being
oversensitive they were proven
absolutely right and in that sense I
think we are listening much more to what
they have to say and we should listen
much more because they they were spot on
frankly do they have the Eastern
European do they have a better
understanding of Russia and of Putin
they have now and they had before we
have to understand that Germany as a
Central State of the European Union was
following a policy that totally failed
this is a political disaster for foreign
for German for foreign policy and
economical policies uh that that were um
implemented during the last 30 30 years
after the fall of the Berlin Wall trade
with Russia
um using Russian gas and in the same
time delivering a lot of goods to Russia
for keeping the fossil fuel industry
running there a lot of equipment was
sent from Germany from the German
economy there so but this policy failed
obviously whereas the Baltic states
Poland and other central eastern
European states have exactly warned of
this scenario and of course it's uh it's
naturally that that that the one who was
right
um at the moment
um when something like this is happening
a war in Europe imagine the first war in
Europe since since the wars in in the
Balkans in the 1990s it's natural I
guess that um this side that that warned
of this scenario has a stronger position
politically also in the European Union
but does it have does it have that
stronger position really yes the Roman
please please do just to follow up uh I
think 30 years maybe it's a too long
perspective to look at it the red red
lights should have gone on in the year
2008 or as Russia fought to war with
Georgia uh and at the latest 2014 with
the annexation of Crimea uh what Germany
tried to do before maybe was not so
wrong to try to establish a new
relationship with Russia try to trade
with Russia but it failed it failed and
it was obvious in 2014 and since then it
was a mistake by the German government
to believe that they could continue more
or less the same doing business with
Russia and hoping there would be no
further war that was the mistake and
this is what the countries like Poland
or the Baltic states were warning about
evidently the many uh pointer Angela
Marco these days as being responsible
for kind of bigging up a Vladimir Putin
would you agree
um well we are certainly rethinking her
Legacy when she left last year she left
in the blaze of glory she was a seen
generally as a wonderful statement
certainly abroad maybe in Germany with a
little bit more Neos
yes I mean it she certainly has support
of North stream too with hindsight seems
utterly misguided in a big mistake
in her defense she rallied other
European union members after 2014 after
the invasion of Crimea for tougher
sanctions so it was actually her brought
the EU together so she I think she
understood quite well where Putin came
from she speaks Russian as we know it's
not that she doesn't understand Russia
but she certainly made mistakes and I
think ns2 was one Nordstrom too that
pipeline was one of the biggest ones
that's I I don't know I I don't buy it
absolutely because she's arguing in the
latest one of the few interviews she she
gave just recently she's arguing that
she argued that she bought Ukraine time
to develop and to become a democracy
that really can defend itself against
Russia nowadays I don't buy this really
because in the same time you have to
look a little bit into the interior
politics of Ukraine Ukraine has has had
many many different presidents
democratically elected since the
Independence at the beginning of the
1990s additionally they had two
revolutions their own to Revolution and
then the the the the the people the the
students of the Euro maidan were the
kids of the orange Revolution which
means there was a process ongoing a
pro-european process a process of
democratization I don't I want to
mention the oligarchy and and the
corruption in this country in Ukraine as
well I I I don't I don't want to
overpain that but as a matter of fact
here you had a development that was very
much comparable to other to other
central European States like Poland this
not not to see that as a Democrat is
kind of
um weird to me you mentioned Poland
there is one country in particular that
has warned again and again over Putin's
intention and is now at the Forefront of
those helping Ukraine with weapons with
Aid and with political influence Poland
does what it can and more
rain side the country is not only a hub
for Western Arms deliveries it also
supplies heavy equipment itself
including more than 200 soviet-designed
battle tanks
in total Poland has supplied weapons
worth almost 2 billion euros to its
neighbor more than any other EU country
the war in Ukraine must be won by the
Free World must be won by Ukraine for us
this is a prerequisite for our safety
it's all about security another reason
why Poland is a model pupil for NATO the
country wants to increase defense
spending from 2.4 percent of GDP to 5 in
addition the Polish military is to be
increased to 300 000 servicemen and
women
Poland is also at the Forefront of
humanitarian Aid the country has taken
in the most refugees
the baltics also support Ukraine with
humanitarian and military aid Lithuania
Latvia and Estonia want Ukraine and NATO
the influence of Eastern Europeans and
NATO and the EU growing
[Music]
so put this question straight to you
vandalina is the influence growing can
Poland for example still be ignored
um no Poland cannot be ignored and its
influence has grown it was proven right
it is doing proportion to its size and
its economic power probably more than
nearly all other countries maybe the
Baltic states um excluded so um so
Poland should be hard and certainly the
power that the center of gravity is
Shifting Eastward but France and Germany
still remain the motor of the EU and the
most important countries
um certainly the Weimar triangle Poland
France and Germany is something that may
be revived I mean I think the juror is
still out because it had been sort of
quite a viable format and then crumbled
but but certainly something is changing
or has already changed
Frank you have reported from let's let's
call it the visigrat states right the
the uh that's the Hungary the Czech
Republic Slovakia and Poland can these
four for example uh maybe including the
the Baltic states can these be viewed as
a coherent block inside the EU not when
you see Poland and Hungary at the moment
because Miss Alba and the prime minister
of Hungary and Budapest is following a
pro-russia policy and they're still um
um try to keep certain ties with the
Kremlin
um I think there's no Unity there
there's a shift between because just
before the invasion of February 24 this
year uh Hungary was very close with
Poland because both uh capitals the
majorities in the parliaments were
following uh nationalistic uh policy
however this is changing at the moment
what I find very interesting is that
when you go to Brussels
um we had talks final talks about a
price cap on uh imported crude oil from
Russia and there was a good chance the
first time since the invasion of
February 24 that Germany would would be
overvoted overruled by a relative
majority in Brussels including Eastern
uh Central VC Eastern European Central
States that you just mentioned that's
interesting because this shows the power
shift in the structure of the European
Union and in the institutions and this
is practically what the founders of the
Lisbon treaty which is the current basis
of the European Union had Insight uh
Roman how do you see this do you see a
growing a palpable growing influence of
the the Eastern European States and the
Baltic states in the EU and also inside
NATO
yes I I do see that and it started
before this Russian invasion in Ukraine
it started after brexit when Great
Britain left the European Union the
influence of Eastern Europe started to
grow but of course countries like
Germany and France Remain the biggest
and most powerful countries economically
and militarily
I'm I think we should we should look at
it like um these countries like Poland
like the Baltic states we should also
not forget Romania which is doing a lot
for Ukraine I've been there and I saw
how much it does to help Ukraine as a
neighboring country to take refugees
military help is coming through Romania
also these countries understand Russia
very good because they have a a very
long relationship with the former Soviet
Union they know what Russia thinks and
how dangerous it is what we are seeing
now since the Russian invasion and um
these countries also remember what
Russia said about a year ago when it
practically bonded the NATO East
expansion to be turned back this is just
just remember the document that Russia
presented they they wanted the situation
of 1997 back again so these countries
understand what is at stake and uh maybe
one more Point uh we should not just
look at um Eastern Europe we should also
look further north to countries like
Sweden and Finland that are joining NATO
and uh their Journey NATO is also making
a shift within the alliance so um maybe
I'm wrong but I think that we are now
facing that this um Eastern Europe and
Northern Europe is something like
Western Germany during the Cold War it
is the front this is where things are
developing where decisions are taking
and this is where the military mind is
also being assembled now I think we've
clearly established that there is a
power shift in inside the EU and also
inside NATO Evalia how do uh the Western
Partners namely France and Germany
see this power shift because they've
created the vacuum really for others to
fill
well first of all the French and the
Germans at the moment it's not the
easiest relationship between Paris and
Berlin so that's that's sort of in a way
contributes to to strengthening the um
Eastern Europeans
um I think there's a lot of Goodwill but
but some of these governments are quite
difficult to deal with in particular the
Polish government opponent has been
heroic in so many ways in this conflict
but on many other issues particularly
the rule of law judges judicial reform
you know their their tensions with
Brussels so it's not an easy
relationship but but I think everybody
acknowledges that Eastern Europeans have
an important voice and one that we
should listen to much more than in the
past do you agreeing of important voices
maybe just one short remark
um the Estonian leader is very present
in the media and she does some very
tough uh tough statements and some even
see her as the new Angela Merkel uh like
a leader of the Western Europe or Free
World
um definitely she's saying the right
things but Estonia is too small a
country to be very much influential and
Paul Poland is also for several reasons
cannot be the leader in that process so
I think it's it's maybe the whole region
that is trying to I would not say um
establish itself as a new center of
power but um is is trying to gain a an
importance
um if we if we look at it just uh like
and and maybe to to spread the influence
not just to Germany and France but to
Eastern Europe as well Frank let me uh
just come back to Frank would would you
agree uh that
the western states
actually welcome
more Eastern European leadership
as a form yes and also democratically
speaking um this should be the case
because you have a certain amount of
millions of people your EU citizens
living in this part of the European
Union and they need representation
interestingly even that we all know that
Poland was criticized very
um rightly about jurgical reform and and
the lack of rule of law uh and and a
renationalization process in the same
time the public in Poland was and is
utterly pro-european more than 60
percent interest rates and opinion polls
said no we want to be in the European
Union and we want to play a role here so
from a um
political democratical view
um we are in a normalization process at
the moment in my opinion yes and no
because I mean all this is conditional
and also the Eastern Europeans playing
by the rules so you know the rule of law
and democracy is important so you can't
say well we want to be more important
and we want to get lots of subsidies of
Brussels but we do a little bit you know
with our Judiciary and the media the
freedom of the media we could do it our
way you know I mean it has to be a
two-way street I agree with you at this
point however I also think that there
are a lot of polls
citizens of Poland who are um wondering
why the European Union and the
institutions as such are not more are
not doing much more against this these
these type of policies and I think here
we have to go back to the state where we
are in the European Union in the
European Union at the moment we are
working on the basis of the Lisbon
treaty and obviously this treaty is not
made for the 21st century as we see now
um because there are not many forms and
possible capabilities of the EU
institutions to intervene and when I say
normalization that also means that we
get this Democratic power from these
eastern central eastern European states
to have their word and I expect that we
will have changes in the structure of
the European Union very soon in
particular when it comes to majority
vote at the moment there has to be
anonymity when it comes to foreign
policy issues in the council this will
change very soon also with the help of
the citizens of country like countries
like Poland this is how I I put it okay
I'd like to come back to to the war in
Ukraine there one billion euros to get
Ukraine through the winter that was the
Pledge of the donor conference and Paris
on Tuesday that's an impressive result
but Ukraine has had enough pledges of
help with temperatures below zero and
infrastructure shot to Pieces Ukraine
says it needs results and fast and not
more promises
we will continue to support Ukraine
for as long as it takes
since the very beginning of this war we
worked very hard together in order to
help Ukraine to resist
and to be resilient and we the European
Union stand here by them in these very
difficult times as long as it takes
hardly a week goes by without new
pledges of Aid being made to Ukraine for
the plight of the people is growing
destroyed schools factories and
hospitals and are repeatedly failing
energy Supply in the middle of winter
moreover the country lacks more than
money equipment weapons and concepts for
peace
who however seems leaderless the once
franco-german axis is no longer a pillar
of support
instead the heads of Europe's two
largest economies are trying to go It
Alone thinking primarily of national
interests is power shifting in the EU
I put that uh to you again vandolina
you've mentioned that the relationship
between Paris and Berlin is not great at
the moment
for years and years and years there was
nothing to be done inside the EU without
the support of France and Germany is
that changing no I think that will
continue to be the case they are just
they're too big those two countries if
you just even look at their population
but
um it could be expanded to a triangle
with Poland but for that I think the
Polish government needs to either change
or be a bit more collaborative
um and um so so the short answer is no
it's not completely changing but it's
going to be
still different with a stronger Eastern
European voice
Frank Germany many pointed Germany as
being the main culprits in in sort of
blocking more help more more and faster
help to Ukraine is is that the view from
Eastern Europe as well
um I think when it comes to a supply of
weapons definitely yes however I think
many people in central eastern Europe do
understand that Germany has the biggest
economy of the European Union is helping
automatically a lot when the European
Union is helping a lot and we just
agreed on a package of 16 to 17
billion euros of help for Ukraine as of
January 23 and that was agreed with
Germany of course it's an interesting
figure because with this package that is
mainly a broader Financial Health for
the for Ukraine as a structure to exist
for for this wartime economy to move on
and and help people that are suffering
terribly at the moment
um the the European Union surpassed the
United States when it comes to numbers
in in help as of next year of course the
United States is still the main Latin
supplier but um you cannot the weapons
are one thing military it is one thing
and to keep this wartime this the state
this nation in in war times running is
another very important issue obviously
and I think people in central eastern
Europe uh do see that
um and I think what is a little bit hard
to understand for many in central
eastern European uh in in central
eastern Europe in these EU countries is
that the shift Germany made politically
since February to 24 is a really major
shift let's start with um that the
federal republic never or tried not to
export weapons into war-torn regions of
the world that has changed completely
um and this we I think at at the end of
the day we will have to see when this
war is over uh who helped what with what
and then we can restart to integrate the
European Union again I want to put this
question to Roman as well Roman do you
agree that there is understanding in in
Eastern and Central and Eastern Europe
for let's say Germany's reluctant
position
well um there was danger of of
misunderstandings and there was a lot of
criticism in Eastern Europe of the
German position uh after the Russian
invasion and before but things have
changed as Frank absolutely correctly is
just said
um look at the figures the recent
figures show us that Germany's number
number one
um weapons supplier to Ukraine in the
European Union and in the whole world is
number three after United States and
United Kingdom and we remember Germany
was very reluctant even to allow
countries like Estonia to deliver former
former Eastern Germans harvardist to
Ukraine this has changed completely and
I think this is something Ukraine very
much appreciates the thing is though
from the Ukrainian point of view
Ukraine very much appreciates uh all
help that is getting from the west and
from Europe militarily economically
humanitarian helped millions of
ukrainians here in Europe but uh the
thing is very simple from Kiev kiev's
point of view you should give us more
weapons so that we can stop this war
sooner because there is not much time
for us the winter is there it's called
Uh the fighting continues Russia is not
giving up so instead of sending us uh
blankets and whatever just send us a
better tanks and planes or military jets
and this is probably something we will
see next year okay I'd like to interrupt
you here because we're running out of
time I'd like to go uh to the final
round uh and to establish is power
really shifting inside the EU inside the
EU and inside NATO uh and where does it
shift to
um it is Shifting it's shifting
eastwards it I think it's a permanent
shift
um but still there's got to be permanent
oh yeah after yes I think but but
Germany and France will still remain for
the time being the motor of Europe and
the two most important countries do you
agree I agree when it comes to the shift
in military because uh this containment
of Russia will have to go on which means
that Eastern Europe and the central
eastern European EU States will be on
the front line for a long period of time
and you agree there will be permanent
for the time being yes okay what's your
what's your take
yes in short it is Shifting and it's a
good thing okay that was a very pretty
final statement there from a Roman I'd
like to thank uh my uh panel here in the
studio that's it from us for today I
hope you enjoyed our discussion we're
curious what you think so let us know if
you're watching on YouTube leave your
comments right down below also hit the
Subscribe button and do share this show
with your friends on social media thanks
very much for watching see you next time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]